it's each standalone episode going to
have its own beats let's let's redo that
question when you are crafting episodes
for serial television are they all the
same beat and the answer is no they're
not and this is both one of the
strengths of the serial and one of the
problems for serial with stand alone the
beats are always the same how you fill
those beats are different so for example
we always have a murder committed in the
opening scene right and then we're going
to go through the beats of solving that
murder by the end of that episode with
serial one of the major ways that it's
different structurally from standalone
is that each episode will be much more
diverse you can have episodes within a
serial that are radically different than
other episodes and it all comes down to
one of the keys structurally for how you
write television whether it's standalone
or serial which is the desire line what
did the heroes of that episode want in
that episode now in standalone that
desire line will be very restricted for
example the detective it's to solve the
crime in serial because we have so many
more characters each with their own
desire line what when we segment each of
this of these season long experience
into individual episodes what those
characters want at any one time will be
radically different and this is the the
downside of that is it's unpredictable
for the audience and if you like that
standalone experience this is just too
much change in difference and I don't
know did we win
on this or did we lose what what
happened here but for people who love
the serial form they like that diversity
they like the fact that they can't
predict what is going to happen to
anyone episode because it's totally
based on cross-cutting among all of
these different characters each with
their own bizarre line
you